[Music]  when I first arrived at MIT as a  freshman two years ago my F pop  counselor to suggest that I joined this  club called dance troupe I'd never  danced before but I figured I would give  it a try for one semester I mean after  all that's what PNR is for right today  I'm a member of redonkulous and Asian  dance team and I'm an officer and  choreographer for dance troupe it's a  lot for sure but it's so so with it  dances helped me become more confident  and comfortable in my own body and the  people are just the best we tease each  other and joke with each other but at  the end of the day these guys have my  back and anything  [Music]  I've been a part of this family for the  first half of my MIT career and I'm so  so excited to see what happens next  [Applause]  you